so this one's gonna make her a little  bit taller she wants to be taller okay  so we take the massage device and we  tuck it up underneath the skull and your  body is on the pillow  so we're tractioning that's like the  heads being traction forward this way  okay and I have just lift up your head  for a second I have the smallest device  here and it's right up underneath the  neck and we're just gonna hold that  there tuck in the chin and after a while  it's gonna relax and stretch like saran  wrap this way and then when she sits up  she's gonna feel her neck will really  loosen up because it's gonna take that  compression and just traction up okay so  that's how you would do the back of the  neck and stretch out the top of the  upper spine